the organization that oversees youth
football nationwide is testing a new
version of the game for younger players
USA Football announced just yesterday a
rollout of its rookie tackle pilot
program to 11 leagues in nine different
states the changes include a smaller
field fewer players and some rule
changes football has been under pressure
for years to address concerns about
concussions and other issues Jeff Glor
is here with USA football's effort to
keep kids and fans involved safe
Jeff good morning Gail good morning to
you it is a new way for kids to learn
the game a transition between flag
football and tackle it means the sport
for millions of kids could be changing
in the years to come but it is not
without sceptics Jake ant-man on a field
in Mentor Ohio two teams demonstrated
rookie tackle forms there are no
kickoffs or punts players start in a
Crouch instead of a three-point stance
there are six to eight kids on a side
instead of the usual 11 and the field is
40 yards long not a hundred right down
this line here would be the would now be
the out of bounds line the executive
director of USA football's Scott
Hallenbeck L says the primary purpose of
this new game is to increase individual
attention and help players develop you
do want this to be a safer version of
youth football we mean absolutely our
focus is always on how do we create a
better safer environment that was on
Kelly Gilchrist mine when she signed up
her nine-year-old son Tyler he's been
playing tackle for a couple years yes
any reservations about that at first we
were a little bit taken back I know that
there's a lot of fears and a lot of
parents that we know that's why we like
the seven-on-seven idea USA football is
targeting a transition phase because
numbers show that while organized youth
tackle football participation is down
sharply in the last five years the
number of kids playing flag football is
actually up the sport wants to capture
that momentum what do you say to parents
now who come to you and express concerns
and said I just don't know if if my son
should be playing alright I'd say come
and take a look at this game come and
take a look at what we're working on
here to teach rookie tackle USA football
is relying on coaches law
Chuck Pyle is 111 high school state
championships in Ohio it's America's
passion but it shouldn't turn into a
gladiator sport and what do I mean by
that people yelling and screaming and
loving it but not out there playing it
that's a shame even as the new program
is unveiled however it is facing
criticism this is their way of saying
that boys of that age are not able to
play the game the way it's designed
Terry O'Neill runs a group called
practice like pros he says all youth
football should be flag football until
high school youth contact football is is
not correct not safe and when there's
another way to play the game why take
those risks are you worried about the
future of football I think actually the
work that we're doing right now is is
going to ensure that this game is around
for many generations to come
those 11 different leagues will be
testing the new version of the game this
fall USA football points out this does
not change the rules of the traditional
11 player tackle game rookie tackle
again is meant to be that bridge between
flag football and full tackle really
important story lots of parents debating
this nice Jeff